[Music]  for some people comic-con means to ven's  big crowds and long lines but what  happens when you've been waiting six  hours to see some cool stuff and  suddenly nature calls you can't lose  your spot and those bathroom lines can  be longer than an imperial star  destroyer sounds like you need a  bathroom buddy bathroom buddies are  fully functional mobile toilets that  double as authentic-looking cosplay  accessories privacy features or for  extra mods  fully enclosed units understand a  variety of configurations handicapped  accessible  [Music]  especially your next bathroom break  bathroom buddy  the buddy you can poop more show cut up  we will be right back stick around  everybody  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you  you